et à dire que le plus grand atout de la
france c'est son peuple un peuple
volontaire un peuple solidaire un peuple
créatif notre peuple je le connais bien
je ça fait des années que je vais à sa
rencontre et je suis obligé d'être
témoin que depuis cinq ans je l' ai vu
souffrir je les ai vus s'inquiéter je
les ai vus s'inquiéter d'un déclassement
d'une sorte de de précarité qu'il
ressent généralisée et puis je les ai
vus s'inquiétait aussi de l'avenir et
douter
je voudrais lui dire que un autre choix
est possible fondée sur le respect est
fondée sur le bon sens
si le peuple français me fait l'honneur
de ma porte et sa confiance dimanche
prochain je serai la présidente du
régalien c'est à dire de la renaissance
démocratique des protections collectives
de la liberté de la souveraineté et puis
de sa sécurité je serai aussi la
présidente du quotidien de la valeur
travail du pouvoir d'achat de l'école
creuset du savoir de la santé partout
pour tous de l'assimilation républicaine
mais aussi de la promotion sociale mais
surtout je serai la présidente de la
concorde restaurer entre les français je
serai la présidente de la justice je
serai la présidente de la fraternité
nationale je serai la présidente de la
pêche civile la fraternité nationale
c'est celle qui unit les français et qui
autour d'un projet collectif leur permet
de se projeter ensemble dans l'avenir
[Musique]